عموما للمزيد من بعض المناطق المنكوبه
لدينا شبكه مراسلينا وبالتالي لدينا الان
من اضنه تحديدا مراسل الجزيره المعتز
بالله حسن المعتز اضنه لا تزال كما نشاهد
في الصور جهود الانقاذ متواصله فيها
وهناك صعوبات كبيره ترتبط بظروف الجويه
وايضا ان الليل ايضا قد خيم مما يزيد من
تعقد عمليات صف لنا المشهد
نعم مياده ما يحدث هنا ربما هو يشابه
كثيرا من المناطق التي تعرضت للزنزال هنا
في تركيا هنا في هذه النقطه من مدينه اضنه
ما زالت عمليه البحث
والانقاذ وازاله الانقاذ وازاله الانقاذ
مستمره خصوصا وانه مضى وقت طويل منذ وقوع
الزلزال تقريبا اكثر من 16 ساعه منذ وقوع
هذا الزلزال وبالتالي محاولات البحث عن
ناجين ما زالت مستمره الاليات الكبيره
الموجوده في هذا المكان هي تحاول المساعده
على ازاله القطع الكبيره من الالقاد هنا
ولكن عمليات البحث المستمره هي تجري عبر
ايادي
المنقذين وطاقم ازاله الاوقات كما تشاهدون
في الصوره لان هناك اعتقاد بان مازال ما
زال هنا احياء في هذه النقطه هذا المبنى
هو مكانه مكونا من 14 طابقا وهو واحد من
16 نقطه اخرى في مدينه اضنه
14 مبنى مشابه لهذا المبنى ربما خلال
الزلزال واثنين في الهزات الارتداديه بعد
ذلك هناك تحديات اهمها تحدي الزمن
للمده الطويله منذ وقت الزلزال لكن الامل
ما زال موجودا بالوصول الى ناجين في هذا
المبنى العشرات بحسب الاهالي في المنطقه
العشرات موجودين في هذه المباني التي سقطت
وبالتالي محاوله الوصول الى ناجين هي ما
زالت مستمره مياده كما تشاهدينا في الصوره
ايضا نشاهد في الصوره المعتز وكانه عدد من
المدنيين يمدون يد العون لفرق الدفاع ليس
كذلك
الجميع هنا يحاول الوصول الى ناجين
الغالبيه العظمى من الموجودين هم من طواقم
انقاذ متخصصه قد ربما الان ما تشاهدون انه
من هذا الطرف هو الناس التي تحاول مد
العون لفرق الانقاذ بازاله
[موسيقى]
الانقاذ الان طلبوا من الجميع الصمت من
اجل سماع اذا كان هناك صوت لاحد في الداخل
هذه العمليه تتكرر مرارا منذ ساعات الصباح
في المناطق المنكوبه من اجل سماع ما اذا
كان هناك احد تحت الانقاض هم
ينادون على الموجودين ويحاولون سماع ما
اذا كان هناك اي احد يرد عليهم
حسن طلبت منه فرق الانقاذ ومن بقيه
الموجودين ان لا يصدر اصواتا لانه هناك
محاوله لسماع اي صوت من تحت هذه الانقاذ
التي تشاهدونها على الشاشه وهذا اجراء
متبع عندما يكون هناك احتماليه وجود ناجين
يحاولون المناداه لاسماع صوتهم
لذلك تحاول فرق الانقاذ جاهده الاستماع
لاي صوت حياه داخل هذا المكان وتحت هذه
الانقاض عموما سنعود الى مراسلنا لمعرفه
المزيد في هذا المشهد وما الذي يجري في
هذه اللحظات